i was in high school and i was playing  in the summer basketball league man it  already feels so stupid all right uh  this kid his name's mike right  you know he wasn't skinny fat boy mike  let's go and so we would always just get  into it you know when you're playing  basketball people start talking [ __ ] to  each other right he'd be like dude you  talk [ __ ] and he called me a fat ass  right like [ __ ] you dude you're [ __ ]  fat ass right yeah yeah yeah  and he would always be like what look  you're [ __ ] fatter than me dude and  like [ __ ] you you're the [ __ ] fattest  dude here right those two  and it literally wasn't until like after  college that i get hold of like a photo  from like summer league  and i finally found out i was  clearly fatter  you [ __ ] see yourself every day right  you don't know  because i was so confused that he was he  must have been like you're fat dude he's  like what the [ __ ]